you
this is the
municipal and county uh
executive session today at
march 1st
and would you please all join me in the
pledge of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic which stands
one nation under god indivisible with
thank you
as a note uh we had some feedback that
it was difficult
for the audience to hear us
yesterday so i would ask you
when you're speaking to make sure the
mic is pointed right at your face
and not pointing up to the sky
and turn your mics on and off
as necessary
okay we have
two folks who are joining us today as
subs
we have uh
sue newman
and we have wayne mcdonald
so welcome to both of you
will you do a roll call mr
mr clerk
yes here
uh yes on the uh vice chairman the clerk
is here
representing the trip
i'm here to
represent guthrie
here
representative los alas here
uh representative mcdonald here
representative melvin here
representative
representing power
majority
here
representative 11
representative gilman
here
representative stavis
representative newman
here
representative vann here
representative gallagher
here
representative ron here
and chairman dolan here excuse me was
that removed from the committee i'm
sorry was i removed i didn't hear my
name called
representative
yes
thank you
so joe can i ask you to turn off your
mic
yes
so don't forget please don't forget that
after
uh you engage with the committee that
you turn your mic off because they're
very sensitive and will pick up things
that you don't
really want them to pick up
okay
we don't have a lot of bills today but
we have a few changes
so we're going to start off by
reviewing bill hb 1223 do we have a
motion
mr chairman
mr chairman i make a motion that we
reconsider house bill 1223
uh
so that we can uh
reconsider that bill to uh
have a different uh outcome
is there a second second
motion's been made and seconded is there
any discussion on that
yes uh could i agree could i
request
uh the
motion maker to speak to their motion
well the reconsider is kind of a
uh
a self-explanatory motion and you want
to know why yeah i i would like to know
why we are reconsiderate
i'll make that optional for you you
don't have to if you don't want to
the
the reason that i feel we should
reconsider this
is to
to do more study on the bill i don't
think the bill is ready to be passed
thank you
any other comments
seeing
none
i'd like to ask
that we we're going to do at this point
is let's review the process we're going
to revoke
the itl motion originally made
and then we'll look at further motions
down the road if that if that
passes
mr chair yes don't we have to first vote
on the motion to reconsider yes we do
okay
and then
as we go through each one of these i
think there'll be about two or three
votes on each
motion that comes forward
so we have on the floor a motion to
reconsider and a second
mr clerk would you take a roll
okay uh vice chairman pmrt yes
click votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
representative mcdonald
representative melvin
yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majority no
representative gilman no
representative stavis no
representative newman
no
representative vann
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong
no
chairman dolan yes
motion to reconsider pass is uh ten to
eight
okay uh representative los alas you have
a
new motion to
yes mr chair i i
my motion is to
re-vote on the inexpedient to legislate
reconsider is that right yes
okay so there is a
a motion to reconsider 12 23 is there a
second for that
i seconded it
we've we voted down the itl
i'm sorry we
we're now going to vote on the ito yes
i'm sorry
our first
vote was to reconsider
the bill
now that it's
been authorized to reconsider we're
going to look at the motions that were
made are on the original bill and that
bill had
passed an itl at that point
so now the
the motion i'm sorry for that confusion
the motion is whether to maintain the
itl or to change the itl
and
representative
lasales
you have a motion
we have to vote on the ito yes what is
your uh mo what is your vote
i'm sorry we're going to go to the clerk
to get a uh
vote on the itl mr chair can we discuss
the motion on the floor please yes we
can okay
uh may i speak sure thank you
um just as we voted on this the other
day i'm i support the itl
i don't think there's any hope for this
bill even if we go to interim study the
fact that it's removing someone from
elected office just for two absences
regardless as if they're excused or not
i can look around this room and already
count how many people would be removed
from their office as state
representative
if the standard of this bill was applied
to the house
i think it's an irresponsible bill it's
vague it's
contrary to what's already existing in
law and in local ordinances
and
it's it's it's it's a travesty if we
can't just put this bill to die a death
and just ask yourselves
if
you would be willing to leave your
representation upon two excused absences
if you're ill hospitalized or whatever
i think um
if if we can't live up to the standard
of this bill we shouldn't expect anybody
else to thank you
yes thank you yes uh
gilman
thank you mr chair
first i'd like to
remind
members that
when we heard the bill originally we had
12 people signed up opposed to this
legislation and only five in support
and the other thing i'd like to point
out is we already have an rsa a state
law
for missing four meetings
so i'm not i'm not in favor of change
lowering it down to two i think that's
impractical
thank you representative klee
thank you mr chair um if i remember
correctly based on my notes
there were um a couple of um
issues that got brought up um and one
was that it conflicted with rsa and i've
written this down i have not double
checked it myself so i apologize rsa
32-15
roman numeral six i believe is what i've
written down as well as
there was um a couple of comments that
we needed to amend the 25 percent to 75
percent
basically we're saying if you've missed
25 percent of the meetings
um
you could be removed
that seems like a very low bar
to remove someone
from a meeting
so i
i am worried that we're going to pass
this without having made these changes
and i think that was one of the reasons
for the itl was that it just wasn't
quite ready for as often too often said
ready for prime time thank you
thank you representative lasallus yes i
i think that the comments of
my esteemed colleagues
with respect to the problems with with
the bill
kind of makes the argument for not to
otp yet but to study it more attendance
at these
meetings is very important and people
who
uh
and the
the bill
does make provisions for people who have
an excused absence so
what what i'm proposing
is that we do an interim study on this
bill but we first have to vote down the
itl
thank you any further yes representative
wrong
i have a question from my friend from
litchfield where is um
excused absences allowed in this bill
i just see on line
and on line 16 it just says fails to
attend two or more it doesn't allow for
any excused absences
at the
top of the bill under the analysis
requires in-person attendance by an
elected member
except under extenuating circumstances
i believe that refers to remote
participation
that unless there are extending
circumstances remote participation is
not allowed
i
i don't see any reference to remote
participation
i don't know that
um it's in line four and five
like a meeting by electronic or other
means of communication under rsa
91-a colon 2.
mr chairman i i just think it needs more
study
to correct it
and that's that's the proposal i have
and i'd like to call a question
okay
seeing no further
comments
uh
i'll ask the clerk to call a role on
whether or not to maintain the itl
on
on 12 23.
okay uh vice chairman pia monty
no
clerk votes no
representative tripp i vote no
representative guthrie no
representative los alas no
representative macdonald no
representative melvin no
representative no
representative power no
representative majority yes
representative gilman
yes
representatives davis yes
representative newman
yes
representative vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan
no
uh
representative tripp can i ask you to
turn off your mic
uh the vote was eight to ten
eight to ten
hey uh
considering that miss uh representative
lasalles you have an additional motion
yes i'd like to make a motion that uh on
bill 1223
to uh
for interim study
second
made and seconded is there any
discussion at this point
on the bill
representative wrong
i really don't think interim study is
going to fix this i think it just needs
to be redrafted
the prime sponsor didn't even speak to
this the person that spoke to it was
someone who has a personal grudge
against somebody on the merrimack school
district budget committee
i think this is just a political
marching order vote
um this is a bad bill
if if we held ourselves to this more
than half of us in the house wouldn't
even be holding our seats
so
i'm disappointed in my colleagues for
even bringing this bill up again
but i'm going to vote
against the interim study
okay any further discussion
yes representative majority thank you mr
chair and and i will add that i hope
that whoever sits on the interim study
will be considering the at least
one two three four other statutes which
will have to be amended in order to
accomplish what this bill may try to
accomplish
uh tough hall it seems to me i wish them
luck
thank you any further comments
seeing that i'll ask the clerk to take
the role
this is an interim study for house bill
yes you want to yes is it
you do want to have an interim study
know is that you do not want to have
internal study
uh vice chairman pia monty yes
collect votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes
representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
uh representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin
yes
representative here
representative power yes representative
mijori
no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative newman
no
representative vann no
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong no
chairman dolan
yes motion passes 10 to
8.
thank you mr clerk
we're going to move on now on to
house bill 1272
and ask
representative lasalle do you have a
motion you'd like to make
yes mr chairman i make a motion we
reconsider
our otp vote on house bill 1272
so an amendment can be presented is
there a second second
second
representative
melvin seconds that motion
is there any discussion on that motion
to reconsider
seeing none
yes representative gallagher um is would
this be the same amendment that we had a
chance to
adopt yesterday but chose not to
i remember yesterday um
you were
asking if someone would like to
introduce an amendment to it because
one had been presented to us
previously but people chose not to so
i'm wondering if this is that same
amendment
it's possible we will have to wait to
see what the motion might be or might
not be
okay
okay uh
seeing no further comment uh
mr clerk would you uh take a roll call
on
whether
we should
uh reconsider
1272.
sure take your time
okay the motion two i reconsider 1272
vice chairman pmonty yes
click votes yes represent a trip
yes
representative guthrie
representative los alas
yes
uh mcdonald yes representative melvin
representative here
yes representative power yes
republican majority now
representative gilman hello
representative stevis no
representative newman no
representative vann
no
representative clee
representative gallagher
no
representative
yes
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 11 to 7.
okay now we have uh before us whether or
not
um
i'm sorry we have before us
that there may be an amendment that we
want to
put on the table and so i'll ask
representative lasalles do you have an
amendment
yes i do and
the amendment that i have is
20220679h
so we have a motion on the table
for for an amendment we'll
make a take a vote on that amendment
and then we'll take another vote
whether we want to
otp as amended
so that's what's that's what's coming
yes representative
stavis question on the amendment i'm
sorry question on the amendment yes
thank you mr chair
should we second the amendment first
did we have a second on the environment
i am
representative melvin second
now that the motion has been made in
second representative davis the floor is
yours
my question has to do with how the
author of the amendment
feels that the amended version differs
from the existing law
what is the substantive change being
made here
that justifies
the change in this existing law
there was a question do you want to
take that question
you don't have to
did did you see the portion of the
amendment that was struck and then the
other was put in
i didn't write that
so i don't have a comment on it
so you're offering an amendment that you
really don't
know why we should support
i just think the language is better
thank you representative
thank you mr chair i'd like to know from
the author how striking
such other regulations related to the
public health
as in their judgment the health and
safety of the people require
is improved by unsanitary living
conditions can the can the author of the
amendment please explain that piece to
me
again that's what
it's your option to take the question or
not
since we don't have the author present
yeah
in my opinion
the
new language makes it more explicit
yes representatives davis
in my opinion it makes it very similar
to existing law
which leads me back to my original
question is why bother
representative power
thank you mr chair um if i remember
correctly the prime sponsor of this bill
came to this committee with an amendment
in hand and as a result of the hearing
and the feedback that the prime received
we have this amendment that's before us
today
so based on my recollection
there was some concern with um the
phrase be repugnant to the constitution
and the prime was willing to remove that
additionally
there was lines 11 through 13 in part
that was not supposed to be in there and
according to my notes
and ols
did
that was an oversight by ols so that's
why that was removed
and then um
again
lines 17 through 30 of the amendment
that came to this committee during the
hearing
the note was that that was taken
directly from vermont
statute
and based on the feedback
the prime sponsor decided also to remove
that in order to make um the bill more
clear
and
finally i would would say that with
regard to the the questions with regards
to how is this amendment different than
current statute i would offer that
it makes it more focused and more clear
and and less
nebulous
thank you thank you representative any
further comments yes representative ron
yeah i support the amendment i think the
bill that we voted on yesterday was
really flawed it was as i mentioned in
my comments yesterday
the fact that the word repugnant is so
subjective it would be very difficult to
give a specific example
also the
10 days
i felt
was
just
it was just a number pulled out of a hat
because there are some
things that can affect
a community that lasts a lot longer than
10 days and i cited coliform
contamination of public water and also
uh cyanobacteria blooms
and i but i i do agree with um
representatives davis's thing i don't
even though i support the amendment i
don't really see how it differs much
from the uh statute
i think nuisances i mean there are some
examples given but
i think
nuisance could apply to a lot of things
um that are already covered
you know that i think the the sponsor is
trying to narrow down but i still think
having the word nuisance in
makes this equivalent to the original
bill but i will support the amendment
thank you
any other
comments representative majori
okay this is a little confusing so i
just i'm going to try to go slow to make
sure everybody's following us including
me
we have in front of us house bill 1272
we've taken a vote to reconsider it
and now at this point it's it's clear
that there is an amendment that needs to
be offered
and once that's been offered then we'll
we'll look what next step it is
depending on how the the amendment is
voted on
so uh
we did we we do have uh
the amendment uh proposed and
seconded by representative melvin
so
i'll ask the clerk if you take a role
please on the amendment
okay adopt amendment 2022-06
vice chairman pm monty yes
eric votes yes
representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie yes
representative losalis
yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin
yes
representative er
representative power
yes
robert majori no
representative gilman
no
representative stavis no
representative newman
no
representative vann no
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
yes
representative run yes
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 12 to 6.
okay so
so we're still on house bill 1272
we voted to reconsider it we voted to
add
an amendment to it and now
we're going to
look see if there's another motion on
the table now that the amendment's been
added
yes i move
ought to pass as amended
on uh house bill 1272. is there a
discussion on the
on this before we move forward
seeing that us
a second
okay thank you i'm sorry uh
representative melvin uh
i'll ask the clerk now take a roll
on house bill 1272 as amended
we're in the voting mode but i'll take
your question
so otpa
um
put your microphone on before you start
okay uh otpa on house bill 1272.
uh representative monty
yes
click votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie
yes representative los alas
yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
represent majority yes
representative tree 11.
okay
uh representative gilman yes
representatives davis
yes representative newman
yes
representative vann
representative klee
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong yes
chairman dolan yes and may i say uh
congrats uh that's not the right word uh
thank you uh representative trilevan for
stepping up and reminding us that you
weren't here during the vote call and
that you did the right thing
17 to 1.
let me put that in consent without
objection i'll place that on the consent
calendar
seeing none uh
i'm going to uh move on
and
believe me we only have one more of
these to do
uh
house bill 1268
mr chairman yes
i'd like to
make a motion that we reconsider
house bill 1268
second
motion has been made in second and is
there any discussion
i seeing none
this is a
vote whether or not to reconsider or not
so i'll ask the clerk to call a role on
that
a vote
yes would be to reconsider a vote no
would be not to reconsider
okay motion to reconsider on uh hb one
two six eight
vice chairman pm monty yes clerk votes
yes representative tripp i vote yes
representative guthrie
yes
representative los alas yes
represented mcdonald's yes
representative melvin
yes representative yes representative
power yes
represent majority no
representative trail evan
no
representative gilman no
representatives davis no
representative newman
no
representative
representative clee no
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong yes
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 11 to 8.
okay uh at this point i'm going to ask
if we have an amendment to uh that's
going to be proposed yes representative
lasalle
yes mr chairman i'd like to offer
amendment
0 six
eight
zero h
on house bill 1268. is there a second
second
thank you uh representative melvin
so we're at this point where uh we have
voted to positively reconsider 1268 and
now
it's been motioned that we add an
amendment in at this point so we're
going to take a mo we're going to take a
vote on the amendment
that's been proposed
any discussion
out available of the city and including
enjoyment of property please explain
those two definitions to me i would ask
for that but i won't get it so i will
say that this does nothing to improve it
it keeps it
benign to say the least and i will vote
for it
okay yes
everything else save us
i would second the comments of my
colleague representative majori
and i would also ask a question i know
i'm not going to get an answer just what
is repugnant to the constitution
can you provide me with a list of things
that are repugnant to the constitution
before you answer that that i think uh
research will show that that's current
language in the rsa
yes
as a matter of
with respect to the
the definition of the word repugnant
i will i recall
when there was a discussion in congress
of the
subject of pornography
the
esteemed senator
suggested that he didn't have a
definition of it but he knew it when he
saw it
how's that
any further discussion
uh yes representative clee
thank you mr chair um i guess
i have some concerns and worries that
we're um
truly tying the hands of our
municipalities
one of the questions that i asked when
this originally came up was um
if we were to pass this and some type of
emergency were to happen
that um the municipality would need to
be able to do that we would have to get
more or less permission from those that
were
currently in office meaning the house
and the senate collectively and i asked
very specifically if something like this
were to happen in november
when we're technically not in session
would we have to call them
in in order to be able to take care of
this emergency
which is why the well-being of the city
was put in and i believe the author very
specifically said to me
we would never
call them in
which truly concerned me
basically we would be letting our
municipalities kind of hang out to dry
and i just don't think it and i think
that the authors that originally put
this
rsa
rsa through
specifically put that statement which
may seem for the well-being of the city
because they knew it would be impossible
to think of every type of situation that
could happen
and i'm concerned that by being specific
as we are by basically saying
only for the enjoyment of your property
we're not taking actually into the
health
of our citizens and i think that um
this is just a bad precedent we're
setting i'm very concerned what we're
doing to our cities um and for this
reason i i will not be voting for this i
would i tell this bill thank you
representatives davis
yeah my
sorry i was god to that representative
gallagher
um
yeah i
want to echo representative clee's
comments um i think the amendment makes
the bill worse
i think enjoyment of property
is
not something we should be prioritizing
over the well-being of the city and so
i'll be voting against the amendment too
thank you
yes representative ron
i guess um i
like the amendment better than the bill
and i'm also
i guess it's up for interpretation but i
would consider
getting very sick
possibly dying to be a nuisance that
would prohibit me from or interfere with
my use and enjoyment of property so i'm
going to support this because getting
sick is definitely a nuisance
thank you uh representative gilman
thank you mr chair um i'm going to
follow along with uh representative
klee's statement
in that the end of at the end of this
excuse me
uh line 19 and 20
any ordinance shall be in effect uh from
the time they're unlimited without
the sanction or confirmation of any
other authority whatever
and any other authority is not defined
so
you know if the select board makes a
decision
someone doesn't like it
they can
appeal to
the
the house or the governor or somebody it
just doesn't give any
um
any meat to the substance of the of the
phrase
thank you uh any further yes
representative salas mr chairman i'd
like to call a question
any further comments
what we call a question
okay we're going to call the question
to reconsider
to adopt the amendment uh that of the
bill that we're reconsidering which is
1268. so we'll need a motion for a new
amendment
representative lasallus
well we already have the motion on the
amendment i'm sorry
okay so now we're going to vote whether
we're going to adopt the amendment or
not
the motion's been made and seconded i'll
ask the clerk to call a
role okay dr amendment zero six eight
o-h
vice chairman pia monty
yes
click votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie yes
representative losalis
yes representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
yes
representative power yes
representative majori yes
representative
no
representative gilman
representatives davis
yes representative newman
yes
represented a van
no
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
no
representative wrong yes
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 15 to 4.
mr chairman so we have yes uh i'll be
looking now for a motion to
uh
to uh do an otp a
with the amendment yes mr chairman i'd
like to
make a motion that we otp
house bill 1268 as amended second thank
you is there any further discussion at
this point
seeing that ask the clerk to call
yes
thank you mr chair um
i
my friend
uh representative guthrie says many
times he sits on the select board i'm
saying the same thing too i sit on the
select board
it's going to be a challenge for our
council and costly for our council
or the city councils excuse me to figure
out
how to define
what the enjoyment of the property is
i i cannot imagine what your legal costs
are going to be to defend that i cannot
imagine how many different uh uh
applicants you're gonna have i don't
think that's the right word
i wish you the best thank you yes
representative
uh thank you um mr chairman and uh thank
you to uh representative missouri um i i
have to echo his words um as a person
who sets not on a select board but on an
all dramatic board
i can tell you that
many lawsuits are brought forward when
citizens are not happy with something
that we've done
and
whether i think we would lose win or
lose i think this is just going to
create more chaos
in
underst trying to do understanding
representative ron kind of made a
comment about relative to
illness being a nuisance
i think we're going to be having all
kinds of
legislative arguments as to what the
definition of nuisance means
is a nuisance that i have a loud
neighbor or a nuisance means that they
they have um
covid and
and so on and i i can i'm concerned
about where this is going
and um for that reason i will not
support the otpa thank you so much
any further questions representative
stavis
is there any further comment
representing the majority are you good
okay uh
so at this point we're going to be
voting
on the otpa
whether we're going to
apply this amendment to this bill
uh so i'll ask the clerk to call the
rule please
vice chairman p monty yes
click votes yes representative tripp i
vote yes representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
representative mcdonald
yes representative melvin yes
representative
yes
representative power
yes representative majority
now
representative no
representative gilman no
representative davis no
representative newman
no
representative
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong no
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 to 9.
okay i don't know about the rescue my
head's kind of spinning right now so
uh i'm going to ask we take a recess for
five minutes let me clear my head and
you can use the restroom
yeah
it was an otp
i'm sorry i should have uh i should have
done that when we were
you
mr chairman would there be any uh
problem with us meeting just to continue
our socialization
yes i'd like to
move itl
on house bill 1342.
i'd like to second that
uh thank you mr chairman
um at the beginning of the meeting i i
handed out a um
a document which is a um
a supreme court um ruling
um for a citizen of nashua versus um
yeah versus the city of nashua as well
as a um
at that point i believe he was a um
an alderman at the time versus um the
the city of uh nashua or specifically
the mayor
of nashua
um and i'd like to bring you to page 10
of that document one of the
conversations that we've had and the
reason for this
bill to come forward was that
nashua and nashua alone does not have an
override provision so if you look down
towards the bottom of that page
you will see
item number two whether the city
spending cap contains an override
provision
the court the court very clearly says
we agree with the trial this is the
supreme court we agree with the trial
court that the city spending cap does
not contain an override provision
within the meaning rsa 49-c colon 12
roman numeral 3 and colon 33 roman
numeral
1 d
rsa 49-c colon 12
roman numeral 3 and
semi-colon 33 i i'm sorry roman numeral
1 d
requires city charter to contain a
provision by which a super majority of
the pertinent body
may exceed the spending cap
if you continue on you'll say that the
sim the the limit on the annual increase
and so on
if you run down to uh on page 11 halfway
through the second full paragraph on
there when it says art in arguing for a
contrary result
sure
i'm sorry page 11
second paragraph full paragraph down
yes
in arguing for a contrary result t-bone
observes that at trial the city's
current mayor who also is mayor in the
1980s referred to the provision allowing
the board to accept certain expenditures
from the the spending cap as an override
provision
the mayor's subjective belief that the
city spending cap contains an overripe
prohibition is irrelevant
to our statutory interpretation
nashua does not have a spending cap and
as such
it's been told over and over again
everyone has an override everyone does
not have an override nashua does not
have this override
this would mean that we would be limited
and unable even with the super majority
to be able to do that
because of this ruling it is my belief
that the original legislation that was
brought through last year was brought
through as such to override
the
the judicial ruling on this particular
thing i'm not asking to overturn
last year's ruling
by the esteemed senator who brought it
forward
i'm just asking that we
consider
providing in there that an
override feature would be able to happen
i'm going to be honest with you
i'm still not sure even with this
that um it couldn't still be challenged
in court
but i did ask or i believe that the um
the author of this did ask
that this feature be put in
and that very specifically state a
two-thirds majority of the governing
body would have to approve that
i think that is what the intent was with
the original one i'm not asking for an
overturn of that spending cap it's done
um truth be told i lived in nashua at
the time that this went through
more than likely i don't remember that
many years ago and sometimes i barely
remember tomorrow yesterday
um
but i do believe that i probably voted
for it because anybody who would come to
me and say to me
by stopping spending i can save you
taxes who in their right mind would not
say yes
i don't want to think of myself as
uneducated but i think the truth is i
didn't look at what the possible
issues could be we often refer to them
here as unintended consequences
and as such because i did not
consider those things nashua has had
some unintended consequences
i do believe over the years nashua did
violate
the no override
and i think out of desperation
that they moved certain monies into
certain areas and so on to try to
override it in a different manner
i don't want to see this happen i want
to see full transparency
and that's why this bill was brought
forward
i think at this point if there any real
flaws in it um
i
truth be told i don't think it'll pass
this
committee let alone the
the house
which truly saddens me because i think
the the original bill was targeted at
nashua and i think the unintended
consequences is we're going to hurt my
city
and um
i'll leave it at that thank you very
much
thank you representative is there
further discussion yes representative
mr chair um may i ask a question of the
representative from nashua yes if you're
willing to take the question yes i am
representative
if there if you do not have the
two-thirds super majority to override is
it a simple majority now to override
technically speaking we don't have it in
the past what we have done when they
have done
this pseudo override it's been always a
two-thirds majority they never once did
a simple majority um and i don't think
that
allowing a simple majority in this case
would be acceptable so two-thirds is the
only way to do it thank you
any further discussion
may i ask rep yes representative power
thank you mr chair um
i find this bill very problematic and
i'm a little bit confused
because in in my mind this bill undoes
sb 52 which was signed into law by the
governor
just last summer and the ink wasn't even
dry on that signature and this bill was
filed to essentially undo everything
that's contained contained in sp 52 and
that was signed into law so i've heard
in this committee comments
from some of my colleagues that we
should not be undoing bills we need to
let them
play out try them out and i'm just very
confused because
those were comments made just yesterday
as well as last
year in committee with regards to
bills that have similar effects
representative
uh thank you for allowing me a second
chance at this
while i do respect my colleague it i
don't believe it was the author's
intention to
to undo sb 52 um as i said it was put
through
for whatever the reasons are i i cannot
judge a person nor should i um and i
apologize because i think my comments
prior did
uh make a judgment call on it but
the main thing here is
it would allow for the override function
i don't believe it gets rid of the
spending cap again
i think maybe if this were put into
court it could be
even as it stands right now
we could be looking at another judicial
um
exception
the
original
spending cap went to the lower court
went to a supreme court
the judge very specifically stated there
was no override
for nashua
there was no override provision no
matter what
basically the body did
nor what the
mayor wanted to call it
having that judgment at this point
forward
there would be absolutely no ride no way
that nashua could misinterpret and say
well
we're going to create an override that's
what this was supposed to do
i've spoken to the author of it i've
spoken to our legal
individuals and so on and it basically
the statement of it any such tax cap or
spending cap does not contain an
override i'm sorry that's page
one line
seven
if any such cap or spending cap does not
contain an override provision it shall
be interpreted to allow
an override upon a two-thirds
super-majority vote of the governing
body
that was my main
concern when this went through
you're right the ink was not dry but
that was because nor was the ink dried
on this legislation from i mean this
ruling from 2019 from the superior on
the supreme court
so
that legislation again i'm trying not to
make a judgment i believe was in
reaction to that supreme court ruling
so again
no override exists in nashua
i'm sorry
i'm talking about on page seven let me
sorry line seven through line nine the
highlighted area
no in our in our bill 1342 sir i'm so
sorry i'm jumping around too much i
apologize for that
i i have to admit i am very passionate
about this
and i'm having anxiety thinking would
have to speak on the floor after six
years i've never spoken on the floor and
i did not want to make this on my first
one but
so i'm already so my hands are ice cold
and i'm already having an anxiety attack
about it but
i am very passionate about it i saw
what not having an override did to the
city
the the streets were falling apart
infrastructure was dropping and i think
that's why
out of sheer
frustration and so on
they created an override i was not on
the board at the time
this was basically overturned by the
time i soon after i got on the board so
thank you and again and i apologize if
i'm
appearing to be contradictory um to to
anyone thank you
thank you mr chair my understanding is
that currently every
existing tax and spending cap in new
hampshire
regardless of whether it was adopted
before july 5th 2011 it does
it does
have a super majority override provision
and also
sb 52 did in fact re which was signed
into law did in fact require that any
municipal action that redistributed
excludable budget items from within the
limit of the cap budget to outside of
the budget cap shall require a
supermajority vote that was one of the
i guess um
that was one of the
things that that
was contained in sb52 and and so i'm i'm
i continue to be a little bit confused
by
the
house bill 1342.
yes representative tripp
thank you mr chairman
i uh
believe that uh my understanding of this
is that even though nasha was
was
very
succinctly told that they need a
a spending cap exclusion
or override
they they
since it requires
a
charter change
they
haven't done it so
the action of this bill is to
essentially negate
that requirement that's found in
rsa 49 c12 you know i i don't understand
why
it is that uh
nashua
should be given this exclusion that all
the other cities and towns have to uh
abide by
thank you uh representative clio is it
any additional information from what you
provided
yes it is but i see that representative
gilman go ahead representative
thank you mr chair i wanted to follow up
on representative power's comments about
the previous bill that was enacted
the lines that were struck include
principal payments and interest on new
miss municipal bonded debt can't be
included in the tax cap and counting
towards the tax cap and i have a problem
with that because
um of the bond issue uh the bond issue
was agreed but then you can't pay for it
the next year
for some budgetary reason
that the bonding rate of the
municipality may go down
thank you representative
um
yes uh my it's more of a clarifying to
what um representative tripp's uh
comment about
why should nashville be any different
actually right now nashua is
the only one that is different
all of the municipalities within their
tax or spending cap have the override
feature
nashua is the only one who does not have
it
so nashua is being singled out in the
fact that they aren't like the rest and
we're trying to make us like the rest
thank you uh any further comment
yes representative
that was exactly my point uh
it seems like the easier thing rather
than changing state law would be just
for nashua to put a
tax cap or spending cap override in
their charter rather than you know us
going to this
thank you uh no i'm not going to take
any further discussion on this i'm going
to recess this bill
and give myself an opportunity to get
some
advice legal advice before we go any
further
so
we're going to
notify representative lasalis and
representative power
that made the motion and seconded that
we're going to
freeze
that right now
and
we'll recess the bill and come back to
it shortly but in the meantime i'm going
to get a little bit of additional legal
advice as to how we should proceed on
this bill
and we're going to move on to the next
bill
okay the next bill is uh 1375
relative to the definition of a veteran
representative lasallis you have a
motion to make
yes mr chairman i move ought to pass on
house bill 1375.
representative do you have a
second to that
i second that motion's been made and
seconded
any discussion on
on that bill
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call a
roll on house bill 1375 for the motion
to otp
okay otp 1375 uh west german pmonty
yes
collect votes yes
representative tripp
yes representative guthrie yes
representative los alas
yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin
yes
representative here
representative power
yes
representative majority yes
representative
yes
representative gilman yes
representative stavis yes
representative newman
yes
representative vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
representative wrong yes
and chairman dolan yes
motion passes uh 19-0 and without
objection i'll place this on the consent
calendar
next bill is 1393
and this is relative to the adoption of
the school district budget cap
and i'll ask representative power she
has a motion she wants to make thank you
mr chair i'd like to make a motion on
house bill 1393 ought to pass
okay is there a second
second
okay is there discussion on on this bill
representative powell do you want to
elaborate on your motion yes thank you
mr chair
this bill is enabling legislation
and it provides the voters of a school
district with the ability to enact a
budget cap
that adjusts annually adjusts annually
the maximum budget
that's based on the number of students
which is the average daily membership
and it can also have an an annual
inflation factor
the inflation factor can be a fixed
percentage or it can be based on an
index from the united states bureau of
labor statistics
so
the school board and the budget
committee
needs to manage their their spending
within the budget cap
and this bill also provides an override
in in this in situations in which
the legislative body feels that
the
budget cap
needs to be
overwritten
so
in my mind this bill provides tools for
taxpayers to control
what i see as unsustainable budgets that
increase year after year despite the
student enrollment going down
and the last comment that i'll make is
we can we constantly and continually
hear about the affordability of
to be able to live in new hampshire and
i would submit to you that part of this
has to do with our taxation
and our spending
so i think that with you know
to to that end
controlling our spending
in turn controls the taxes which in turn
makes new hampshire more affordable to
live
okay
representative stavis
go ahead representative
thank you mr chair
um
the statement has been made
that spending
is this better yeah statement has been
made that uh
unsustainable spending and
school districts and other bodies
needing to be accountable for their
budgets
which certainly is laudable
but what about education freedom
accounts the house just voted that
they do not need to be accountable to
any agency for their budget
what is the
logic
behind making school boards
live within these constraints but
allowing education freedom accounts to
wreak havoc with the state's funds
okay representative gilman
thank you mr chair i i just had a couple
of things to uh to add to that which is
a very good point um
there were
on the electronic submission
108 opposed to this bill and only 44 in
support
i'd also like to point out that the new
hampshire school board association
opposed this because of the fixed cost
question
of whether how that was going to affect
the cost per student and therefore the
quality of the school and education
the other
was that i had i questioned where what
was the source of the 15 percent drop in
student enrollment and was told to look
at the department of education's website
which i did and found in the past 10
years the
decrease in enrollment was about three
percent
thank you mr chairman
representative majori
i i defer to representative true 11 who
might have represented
don't say anything nice it's okay
representative gilman i'm sorry i
couldn't hear the last
part of what you said
about percentages
uh we were told at the uh
in the um hearing that the decrease in
student enrollment was 15
and when i did my calculations from the
department of education it was is quite
lower three percent over four thank you
representative majority
thank you mr chair um
so if i understand this bill correctly
if a district receives a special needs
student
uh who moves in that would cost
my community we'd be looking at we
estimate about three hundred thousand
dollars
and the board there's there's no
majority to override the tax cap then
we're on the hook for the full cost of
that special needs student which we have
an obligation to
and in my community three hundred
thousand dollars is three heads three
people
so we need to fire three because you
can't find three hundred thousand
dollars in pencils and toilet paper
so three hundred thousand dollars we
need to fire three teachers in order to
be able to afford that special needs
student which we'd have an obligation to
i am opposed to this bill
thank you
yes representative power
thank you mr chair um
i
would like to respond to the
representatives comments
i would say that
with
within any budget
difficult situ difficult decisions must
be made and i it's not clear to me why
the response is always
to
reduce teachers there are other areas in
any given budget which reductions can be
made so that would also that would be a
choice
and i would also like to add that with
regard to special ed
students
do we not have catastrophic aid for
which we can apply to that that would um
go to pay for the education of such a
student
thank you for further discussion yes
representative
yes thank you i'm opposed to this bill
and to address representative powers
comment about catastrophic aid that
doesn't kick until the following year so
the school district has to front that
money and if they don't have the ability
to cover that cost
they will have to fire teachers i know
in merrimack
about 75 at least of our budget is
salary and benefits
so there's no way that you can absorb a
cost of a special ed student without a
reduction
in staff
and
um get to that point when you reduce
staff
um
you're you're increasing class sizes
you're reducing services even to
our typical students so it has such a
huge effect all over the district
and the fact that this override has to
be done by the legislative body
sometimes districts within a school year
have to make
accommodations and to call a special
meeting
i think is very expensive and also
getting back to special ed and
i don't know about your districts but
many times when we fail to serve our
special education students
we risk spending a lot of money on legal
costs
because that's a federal requirement we
also risk accreditation if a spending
cap causes us to increase
class sizes
reduce maintenance costs there's so many
parameters that go into accreditation
many years ago when i served on the
merrimack school board which i i served
for almost nine years our accreditation
was at risk because of class sizes so
it's not an easy decision to let go of a
teacher because you're putting much more
risk
to the school district and to the
students thank you
representative clee
thank you again mr chairman i i want to
echo my colleagues um
answers and i want to say that i am
grateful that this is enabling that that
does
um make that pill a little easier to
swallow but the um
the key here that i keep honing in on is
that
if 70 to 80 percent of the costs
to any school budget is the variable
cost of personnel
there's no doubt in my mind that in
order to save a significant amount of
money we would have to reduce personnel
so where do you reduce it and sadly
as was pointed out
teachers are probably one of the first
to go or pairers or something of that
nature which means we are affecting the
class i think it was pointed out then a
three hundred thousand uh dollar cut
could mean you know three or four
teachers or a number of pairs which
means we're going to increase the class
size
we're going to be putting more students
in and the thing i keep hearing over and
over again is that public schools don't
work the classes are too big private
schools have much smaller classes
etcetera etcetera where we're setting
ourselves up for failure
yes this is enabling but if a district
does put it through
the hoops that they're going to have to
jump through again i always run back to
the unintended consequences i don't
think
anybody here in this room or on the
floor
will want to have larger classroom sizes
less teachers less paras
less resources for our students in
public schools
by law we are required to have
public schools and fund them
appropriately
we have these freedom choice accounts
which
may or may not be taking i'm not going
to debate that away from the public
schools but the problem that we're
having is we keep talking about reducing
their budgets we keep talking about
bigger classroom sizes
that means less resources i fear for our
students of tomorrow in the public
school systems if we keep doing this so
for this reason um i cannot vote and not
to pass on this even though it is
enabling thank you thank you
representative powell your additional
comment
no waving off
any further comments from the committee
seeing none we have uh on house bill
1393 we have
a motion
to otp this bill and a second
since there are no further comments i'll
ask the clerk to call level
okay otp 1393 vice chairman p monty
yes clerk votes yes representative trip
yes
representative guthrie
representative losalis
yes
robert mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative majori no
representative tray 11 no
representative yeoman no
representatives davis no
representative newman
no
representative fan
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong no
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 to 9.
thank you
moving on to house bill 1406
which authorizes municipalities to
collect compost representative tripp
view emotion
i'd like to make a motion of otp for
house bill 1406.
representative do you have a motion
thank you
is there any discussion on this yes
representative majori
thank you mr chair um once again just
like the 11 22 i'm going to have the
unfortunate pleasure
of notifying the sponsor that we passed
his bill
um because he was hoping that this one
might go to interim study so that the
des regulations now that are updating
rules for recycling and compost uh while
those are working through he thought
that they might improve this bill
so he actually thought after
conversations that interim study would
be a better idea ought to pass is fine
because it gets us where we need it gets
improvement
it does get improvement but it may
require revisiting the bill as long as
we are clear with that i'll let them
know that next year we may have to tweak
what if we approve the bill so either
way you go on this i think the sponsor
is going to be okay thank you
further discussion
yes representative tripp uh
i uh i agree with my fellow
representative uh
there's probably needs to be some more
work done on this but
all this bill really allows
towns to do
is to
collect compost
or
contract with
another
company to uh to collect the combustible
materials so it's one of these things
where uh
this is just the first step in in
probably many steps in uh
being able to uh provide a revenue
source for towns uh
by
their being able to sell or whatever
compost so
i support this bill
thank you
representative newman can i get you to
click off your mic please
is is there any further discussion
on composting
seeing nine i asked the clerk to
to call the role on otp on 1406.
vice chairman pmit
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp
i vote yes representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative mijori
yes
representative
representative gilman yes
representative davis yes
representative newman yes
representative vann yes
representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
and shannon dolan yes
otp passes 19-0 without objection i'll
place that on the consent calendar yes
um so
question if it goes on the consent
calendar can floor amendments still be
brought to it or would have to be pulled
from the consent calendar for that to
happen uh i i believe you have to pull
it from the consent
and it only only takes one member of the
400 to pull it from consent so
if you want to if if you don't want to
under consent i won't no you you you you
can put it on consent i don't want to be
the one to do that but i was just
wondering for
reference first like to familiarize
myself with process here
it takes one representative to knock
something off consent and it will go to
the floor for a vote
so consider that as you uh
as you look forward to the next
session that we have
and you you're going to want to
alert the house clerk
i would imagine your your
your leadership team would want to know
this also
so you're going to want to alert
representative majori but
process wise the clerk needs to know if
you want to pull something off
of consent
before the session starts
any other comments on the on our process
seeing nano gonna take up now house bill
which is relative to housing projects in
the community development finance
authority and establishing a committee
to prevent state sub subsidies for
housing development that is not income
sensitive
representative tripp do you have a
motion to chair i do
i move uh
uh itl on house bill
1617.
is there a second i second
thank you
is there a discussion on this may i
speak to my motion yes you can speak to
your motion first the uh in preparation
for
today's executive session i
looked around to see
what other
law exists in uh
162.
and
i found in uh
if you look
a little higher
in uh
section l
colon 12.
it states
that uh
in allocating funds under the community
development block grant program the
authority shall give priority
to activities
whereas this is directly contradictory
to
the bill it says that
the
shall be funded funds shall be limited
to housing for persons with lower
middle income
if you look at
l13
it says these may include but are not
limited to
and
once again if you go back to the the
bill it says shall be limited to
now there seems to be some housekeeping
that needs to be done in this bill
to
correct
the
the opposition to the the bill that's
being proposed as to what
law exists
thank you
uh representative gallagher
um
so
i i seem to remember that
this bill hearing from
the prime sponsor that he intended to
withdraw this bill and
asked us to vote itl on it and i
remember knowing that at the time of the
hearing so i'm wondering
if someone could help refresh my memory
if we actually did that then if we are
we've already it'll this or
if we still need to vote now this is the
first itl of record that i'm aware of if
anyone else has a different memory on
that let me know
yes uh representative
and then we'll go to representative
powell
yes i also remember that uh the prime
sponsor asked us to itl this bill we
heard it and we discussed that at the
time we heard it
that the sponsor wished to have it
um disposed of because it actually
doesn't work the way he thought it would
so we haven't yet voted on it but it is
the request of the sponsor that we itl
this bill thank you representative power
thank you mr chair i um
my notes say exactly what the
representative just um commented okay
great representative maturity do you
have any comments on oh i should have
turned my mic off i'm so sorry mr chair
it's all right i was just double
checking because we we i think i just
heard all this i thought we already
exact it because the sponsor wanted to
itl so i just wanted to make sure that
we have we weren't running a foul of an
extra vote but i think we'll get to the
same place thanks thank you
any further discussion before we take a
vote
all right we have a motion
and it's been seconded to itl house bill
1617. i'll ask the clerk to take the
role please
vice chairman pmit
yes
clerk votes yes representative tripp i
vote yes r3
yes representative los alas
yes
mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes representative
yes representative power yes
representative majori yes
representative tray 11 yes
representative gilman yes
representative davis yes
representative newman yes
representative fan yes
representative clee
yes representative gallagher
yes
representative ryan yes
and chairman dolan yes
no ice cream 19-0
there'll be no ice cream during
executive session
hey without objection i'll put this on
the consent calendar
19-0
without
further ado let's let's move on to house
bill 1667
which is relative to the standard and
optional veterans tax credits
and the all veterans tax credit
representative powell did you want to
make a motion
thank you mr chair i would like to make
a motion ought to pass on house bill
1667.
second
wilson made in second and representative
powell do you want to speak to your
motion yes thank you mr chair this bill
rectifies a number of discrepancies with
the current veterans tax credits
under rsa 72.
first it um
rsa 2150 defines a veteran
and this definition does
under the all the veterans tax credits
the definitions aren't are not aligned
so what it does is it brings those in
alignment and also
under
rsa 72 those veterans tax credit
sections it excludes currently serving
veterans which is
not consistent
with the definition of a veteran and
this legislation corrects that and
i guess
notably that this bill
includes active duty
service people
so that they can qualify towards that
90-day
requirement in order to
qualify for the veterans tax credits
thank you is there further discussion
on house bill 1667 yes representative
clean
uh thank you uh mr chairman
um in in doing some homework and so on
and looking at
title 38 usc 101 under definitions and
definition of veterans
does in fact exclude any active duty it
refers to
a veteran as
they who have served
within the military and so on so my
concern is that when we roll active duty
into this while um i want to do as much
as i possibly can to active duty
where we could possibly be running a
foul um in that
when a
veteran qualifies for this they have to
be a resident of
that community etc
when someone is active duty and they are
stationed overseas or in another state
they still reside for all intent
purposes of voting etc
within that community so they might
resolve reside in merrimack
thus being qualified for the veterans
credit but not physically being there
that is my concern about the active duty
portion of it
[Music]
so
the
the dd214 is basically discharge papers
and it is something that is often used
in um
that particular thing so again i i refer
back to title 38 usc 101 definitions
where it does talk about a veteran
versus an active member of the service
so
um i i'm just concerned that we are
kind of mixing apples and oranges in
here so thank you
thank you just uh to add on
representative cle's
discussion
the
veterans
vote
at their home of record
and
we haven't defined that yet your home of
record is where you lived before you
went into the
service so if you if you lived in nashua
and you joined the marines
and you're now in
south carolina in boot camp
and election comes up
you have to obtain an absentee ballot
from nashua and you vote in your home of
record there you don't vote down in
south carolina
yes representative clee
that's kind of what i was
alluding to i apologize if i misstated
it
that was the point i was making if you
went into the service and you lived in
nashua merrimack or whatever national
home and you owned a home at that time
when you went in
that in fact would be your um place of
residence and therefore you're voting um
from there so i i'm sorry if i
i do tend to stutter over my words okay
thank you representative gallagher
so um
i i was just reviewing my notes from the
hearing on this and um
one thing i had noted down was that
there were concerns about
um
possible overlap
with um house bill
1375 which
um
which
we already voted to pass today
um
so
i i didn't quite
catch whether those concerns were
addressed or not so i was wondering if
someone could just
remind me about
the how the interactions between this
bill and house bill 1375 work
okay i'll ask any volunteers that want
to speak to that
yes representative majori
unless someone else would like to i
think i was the one who who muddied the
waters on that one and i i apologized
my concern was that if 1375 didn't pass
and we didn't change
what the definition of honorably
discharge or clear that language up
about honorably discharge and discharge
with honor if that didn't pass
then we'd have to clar it would make
sense to try to clarify it here but
since 1375 went through
what'll happen is
this this uh this bill notes
that statute that was being amended so
everything should be fine and i
apologize that i just wanted to make
sure it was a dotting of the eyes and
crossing of the t's and it seems to i've
done that so thank you thank you for
that clarification any further
discussion
yes representative
wrong
yet my concern is with by including
active duty service people
um shouldn't this require a fiscal note
because uh i'm just thinking of
merrimack and anecdotally we have a lot
of there's i can probably think of six
to eight people just that i personally
know
whose
child's
home of record is in merrimack but
they're serving overseas or in
you know away from home in a military
base so there would be
this uh it would be it would have a
fiscal note on it should have a fiscal
note on it so that communities can be
prepared for any
tax impact
i notice it also takes effect 60 days
after passage so
it would take into effect before
likely before or during a budgetary year
rather than
being effective
at the start of a new budgetary year
thank you
yes
thank you mr chair
um
unfortunately somebody's going to have
to remind me but i think we had a very
long and substantive conversation
about several previous
tax credit tax exemption bills
for certain classes of people
and how that would have
something to the tune of 55 million
dollar impact in downshifting property
taxes to excuse me
excuse me mr chair
yes to other new hampshire residents
uh
should we not be having the same
conversation about this bill as all the
others and if not why not
thank you for for that input
is there any further discussion on the
bill before we vote on it
oh
yes
representative gilman
thank you i would just like to um
either point out or ask for
agreement that
uh towns that have adopted the veterans
tax credit would
need to re-adopt this if the legislation
passes
that was my
understanding in the notes that would
have to be re-adopted
thank you um
representative
thank you mr chair um
i was thinking the same thing that
my colleague from lebanon
had brought up we did have a very
substantive discussion in regards to
one class of people's
putting the burden of one class of
peoples on another class of people so i
don't think i'm saying that correctly i
hope you know what i mean
and i'm very
very wary of doing that i
wholeheartedly support
our united states military and all their
veterans of course
um
and want to give them as much
support and help and
well thank you uh
i think the words you were reaching for
was
a tax shift from one set of voters
that's exactly correct thank you very
much mr chair i was looking for that
word um
so i'm not in favor of this thank you
representative
again thank you for allowing me a second
chance to speak um i do want to
reiterate the um
the attack shift and
and so on um
and the previous ones that we
basically uh passed on so to speak with
because it was exactly doing that i know
that um some people say that it's only
about you know one percent of the of the
current um
that are currently serving are are going
to be homeowners and so on i i think
that we're going to see that number
significant
i think when
um active duty
decide that they're going to be retiring
they oftentimes try to get a um an
assignment to
an area so that they can retire in that
area they put down routes they
they buy homes
i think new hampshire
we attract a lot of veterans because we
are so veteran friendly so i think that
these veterans that are going to be
retiring
will be coming i'm not saying they're
going to come in droves and we're going
to have massive amount of people coming
in at 1. but when i look at the current
statewide tax loss meaning tax shift tax
burden of almost 32 million dollars and
we're going to add to that
even if we only added one percent to
that we're still adding to it
and
that means young families are going to
be picking this up
and i'm very worried and very concerned
about it so
i want to do everything i can for our
veteran for our active duty but there
comes a point when we have to kind of
slow the roll
we've done it in the last few bills
i think we need to take a breather see
how everything is happening it seems
like every year we just have one more
after another of a different group of
people so thank you thank you for that
input yes representative power
if i understand the comments correctly
there's a concern of an influx of active
duty service members
coming to new hampshire to reside i'm
not aware of any
military bases in new hampshire
that
house
active duty troops
the
peace area the area outside of the
manchester mall the uh
i'm i'm talking bases
well let's make sure representative
power is finished first
i know that this hanscom air force base
but i'm not
my understanding is that pease is no
longer an active air force base it's
been
downgraded so i'm not sure what what the
reference is at this point
thank you representative
thank you mr chair thank you
representative power for the question
you're correct fees is no longer an
active air force base yes it does yet it
does house
the air national guard
um
that's their headquarters are there
and i don't i don't know the numbers um
of how many people are there but they
are consistently
coming and going and working in that
space
yes representative power thank you mr
chair that the mission of the any
national guard within the state is to
serve the state
so it makes sense that those service
members would reside in the state
correct thank you
representative
uh thank you again um
i i started my
last year's career with the
federal government in dod
i went from there to the veterans
affairs
area of the federal government and
i can tell you that when someone does
retire
they will ask for an assignment
sometimes the assignment is a base
sometimes the assignment can be with a
business so for instance i had a lot of
military that worked with me when i
worked with the um avco
it was called the air force plant
representative office that was out of um
massachusetts yes
but a lot of those people still lived
and bought homes in new hampshire
i worked
at a variety of different areas i have
friends who work in hanscom
and that that is where they're assigned
they have homes in nashua
one of my constituents that i just spoke
to yesterday
moved this way and was assigned to
peas
i've talked to those that have been
assigned to otis granted that's a cape
you know nice place to live and so on
they don't always live next to where
they're assigned to
they're going to buy a home where they
feel that they want to retire and part
of that reason is when they move the
federal government helps them move
so they're going to try to move
sometimes they move and get an apartment
and then sometimes they buy a home so
just because we don't have a large
active base doesn't mean that the people
aren't going to be coming to new
hampshire so thank you
thank you
representative
thank you mr chair
just for clarification um in
appreciation of
my colleagues comment about the national
guard i looked it up real quick and the
peace air national guard base is the
157th air
refueling wing which is
its primary mission is refueling to all
u.s armed forces
and allied nations aircraft extending
their flying range
with the capacity of transporting cargo
personnel
and medevac
operations additional missions include
homeland defense
and air traffic control
and they are the future home of the kc
46a pegasus air refueling tanker
um
they may or may not live in new
hampshire but it's definitely a national
mission that they're
providing only common i wanted to make
for clarification thank you thank you
representative tripp
well i'm i'm sure we could probably
solve this problem of acting duty
members moving to new hampshire by
simply
getting rid of
all the bases because i'm i believe that
the amount of money that
the bases bring to the local economy
far outweighs
any money that
the veterans are going to get from the
veterans tax credits so
possibly we should look into that thank
you let me give you a real life example
um
meaning me
when i left the military
they said where do you want to go now
and i said i want to go home
so
they said well your home of record is
nashua new hampshire
and it's
about 1400 miles from where you are
right now
so we will rent you a moving van
and put all your stuff in it and we'll
move you up to 1400 miles in any
direction you want to go but no more
than that
so i took the
1400 miles and i came home i didn't go
to a military base or i didn't go to
a guard unit i just went home
so that's that's my personal experience
if that adds anything to the discussion
yes representative power
thank you mr chair um unfortunately i
missed the description that
my esteemed colleague gave with regard
to the what
what's going on at peace
and i will look it up when when i get
home and my comment would be
i'm not sure if that would have been a
reserve component at peace
so
and the last thing that i'll say is
that this is enabling legislation if a
community and the majority of the people
in the community do not want to provide
this these types of tax credits then
they do not need to
vote it in
new information or i don't want to start
an argument here
i i apologize if i appear to be that
right no my question is going to be that
it is enabling but if we pass this
and a community doesn't want to do it
they would have to roll back
their current
um credit
i just want to make sure that i
understand that that's all i'm asking so
in other words if a community already
has this
the the um standard optional
veterans tax credits but they did not
want to have to add these additional
people to it
um there's no
way that they can say i'm just not going
to add these additional they would have
to roll back their current veterans
credit for all credit is that correct
okay
anybody
have a
stronger knowledge of that of how the
veterans tax credit would play out
okay i think i'm going to move the
question um
oh i'm sorry representative
no merrimack has a veterans tax credit
already so if this bill were to pass
we would have no choice but to extend it
to
those that continue to serve
which
it's kind of strange because
you know in line four it says is a
veteran
in line six it says continues to serve
so that's
definitely a conflict with title 38
it doesn't seem to make much sense but
merrimack will
will have their taxes increase because
of this if this passes and i i want to
just reiterate my concern that this does
not have a fiscal note so i won't be
voting for it
thank you
representative power you have new
information
well i would just like to say the reason
why continues to serve is to make it
abundantly clear what the purpose was so
that
okay thank you as a as a
sponsor of this bill you would have the
most knowledge
any other
comments
before we take a vote all right we're
voting on 1667
and we have
a motion to otp and a second
yeah ask the clerk to take the role
representative p monty
yes
click votes yes
representative tripp
yes yes representative guthrie yes
representative los alas yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin yes
representative here
yes representative power yes
representative mijori no
representative
no
representative gilman no
representatives davis
okay
representative newman
no
representative vann
representative clee
no
representative gallagher
representative wrong no
chairman dolan yes
motion passes 10 to 8.
okay
before you start packing your things up
uh we're gonna go back
and tackle house bill 1342 which we took
a recess on
uh our legislative assistant
did some research
during our
our
process today
during that recess he went and
spoke with
legislative legal
and the feedback he got was that
the bill that we're considering 1342
does not contradict
the
supreme court ruling that was brought to
our attention
by representative klee
so
so we're gonna we're gonna
we have a motion and a second
for an itl
on
so representative klee uh thank you um
and and thank you for getting that
information i don't think there was ever
a question that this bill contradicted
the supreme court
decision i think what
um
the what the supreme court decision
proved was that nashua does not have the
override ability and hence the reason
for
this particular thing was to put in
an override provision for nashua um
so i never felt that the um
this bill contradicted the supreme court
the the comment was that
because of the supreme court decision it
proved
that the necessity to have this
particular
um
comment not um that there was
contradiction between the supreme court
of this one so that that was the reason
for my bringing the supreme court
decision to all of you
to show you um what the decision was and
what the statements were made and so on
um i never felt there was a
contradiction to it i just felt that um
without this bill
nashville has no override provision even
though in the past
they may have done it
what i'm saying is now we know for a
fact
that the supreme court has ruled we do
not have it so to do it would be
illegal
and i personally as a board member don't
want to do anything illegal yet my hands
will be tied as for being able to put a
charter change that takes time you need
to get signatures
um and that just has not happened
yes
i i understand the motions i want this
to pass
or you want it to pass i want this to to
pass um
because we need it we need the override
we need those lines that are on
seven through nine we need this to pass
i'm not i'm not concerned that this uh
there anything like this i'm just
concerned that right now nashua is the
only municipality
with a cap that has no override ability
and the supreme court decision proved
that and showed that we have no override
ability and sb 52 did not
allow nashua to have an override ability
it overrode the supreme court decision
that said
it was unenforceable
is the way i think that the decision
came down from the supreme court but it
did not give us an override provision
okay thank you for that clarification
representative
michael put your microphone on paul
thank you is nashua the only one that
can't do this in the state
yes we are
well that doesn't seem too fair to me
any addition yes representative majori
thank you mr chair
in the effort to treat like things alike
we we've spent uh quite a bit of time on
other bills trying to make sure that
language comports and
we're trying to we're trying to make
nashua have a two-thirds majority to
override something which is kind of
restrictive and they want that
just so that we have clarity i'm all in
favor of that
thank you
representative tripp
i guess i have a question
why is it that every other town
has an override capability except nashua
representative can you tackle that oh
absolutely um and and i'd love to tackle
it this was one of those um
i don't want to call it community i'll
call it a citizen
charter this was one of the um
the
citizens groups that got together
and got all the signatures that needed
to get a ballot question
and when you do that and they write the
question
and they were very specific about how
they wrote it and so on and it passes
you must put it in the charter as
written
so in order to make any changes to it
you have to do another charter change
etc so
it was not written
by the city of nashua it was written by
the citizens group and an override
provision was not put into it so i hope
that answers your question
representative
yes it seems that this this
cap
was
instituted
based upon a referendum
of all the citizens
then
i feel that to make changes to that
to
override this cap
should
also
require
a referendum
to change the tax cap
to to
implement even though it's a super
majority and i understand my colleague
majori
was talking about a two-thirds vote but
it's a two-thirds vote
of the alderman it's not a two-thirds
vote
of all the citizens
so if we're going to institute
a major change and and having an
override
to this is a major change
then i think it needs to go back
to a referendum
that's just my personal feeling
thank you
yes representative uh
another question
oh what wait a minute uh representative
troop
went up in front of you i'm sorry
thank you
i'm not trying to muddy any waters and
certainly anybody
who's also from nashville can clarify
this i was on the school board in nashua
when this went in it's a spending cap
not a tax cap
and one of the illustrations that one of
our aldermen made at the time and and i
respect the fact yep it was voted on and
whatever
there was a an illustration that
with a spending cap
you could literally bond and get a
school built but you could not afford
because of spending cap restrictions you
might not be able to outfit the school
with desks chairs whatever so
there was some awareness that it was
problematic
it got to be
as as representative earlier said though
people responded to
understanding that their taxes
would be limited and that's what they
responded to
and the override provision
that
frankly when i was on the school board
way back then i thought we had one
and there were instances when
10 aldermen would
quote override
but i would
really i think we need this to clear
things up in nashua thank you thank you
representative newman
yes representative gilman
thank you mr chair i i would
i want to thank the representative for
bringing up the difference between the
spending cap and the tax cap i believe
in this
legislation the only time a spending cap
is referred to is on number line four
and the rest of it all has to do with
tax caps
so i would argue that this legislation
would be ineffective
because
it doesn't
all the details of what you can do with
the tax cap are not included with what
you can do with the
spending cap
representative clean
uh thank you i'd like to address um
representative los alas um i i don't
disagree with you that um
you know this should possibly at one
point go back to the people the problem
is we're here and we're now in sb 52
past last year
um we don't have time to get a ballot
question now we're looking at two years
we didn't have time once sb 52
passed to get it on that particular
election the next election coming
through it will be a
federal election and not a municipal
election so we can't get it there we're
looking at two more years of having to
deal with this
and um i have anxiety as to what those
two years should do
i have brought up the fact that we
probably do need to implement the
charter change and we do need to put a
referendum on the ballot so i don't
disagree with you but we're here we're
now and we've got two more years plus
of what this possibly could do to the
city of nashua and
i saw what it did in the past and now
that we really do not have override even
though we may have done it in the past
we would be remiss if we openly did it
now
knowing what the supreme court has said
that we do not have this so
again i appreciate your time and thank
you so much for indulging me i i know
there's some urgency to call the
question but i'm going to allow
two more speakers and then then we're
going to be done representative tripp
i withdraw
yes representatives davis
so um
with gratitude to my colleague
representative majori refreshed my
memory on how we voted
on hb 1081
which was to um not require
a two-thirds majority to dissolve a
village district but let it go
at a
simple majority
so in that case we were comfortable
with the simple majority in this case
we're insisting on a super majority
can somebody point out to me the logic
in that
they want to tackle that question
i'll tackle that
with the village district
issue
it's a simple majority to form a village
district
and
i don't see why you would require a
super majority to dissolve it
and
since i spoke to that previously if you
give me some time i can find
where uh
that
resides in in the
law
if you're if you
you only have about 60 seconds
are people interested in and why
it's only a simple majority to form a
village district
i think we're getting close to being
non-germane not
house available 1342 and i appreciate
your
your indulgence as we had to went to
research and went to an attorney
and i think we've got this thoroughly
covered and spoken to so i'm going to
ask
the clerk
to call the question i'm going to remind
all of us that this is an itl
it's been motion's been made
by
representative lacelle and has been
seconded by representative power and so
now we're at a point
where
we're going to call them we're going to
call the ask the clerk to call the
question on an itl
vice chairman p monty
yes
click votes yes representative tripp
representative guthrie no
representative silas
yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin no
representative here
no
representative power yes
represent majority no
representative tray 11. no
representative gilman
no
representative davis no
representative newman
no
representative van
representative gallagher
no
representative no
excuse me
i didn't get a chance to vote
yes
okay the uh i believe the motion
field
uh representative piamonte do you have a
new motion to make
what was the vote mr clerk
could you put your microphone on please
i know
uh 7-12
7 to 12.
mr chair i'd like to make a motion
interest interim study
for bill 1342 1342
is there a second for that
motion's been made and seconded
is there any discussion at this point
yes
thank you and i hope this doesn't mean
that i don't get to vote
um
my firm belief and i think it was even
mentioned here by a representative who
filled in in the past that an interim
study is equivalent to an itl
um that it will go nowhere and that it
would possibly die and i don't mean to
be critical um it's just a concern that
i have i think this is something that
needs to be addressed and it needs to be
fixed so i would hope that we will vote
against an interim study thank you
further discussion yes representative
power
thank you mr chair um
my comments would be this is in fact
it's a complicated issue
this this bill is
curious
we had sb 52 that came through this
committee last year was signed into law
so
all totaled this is a complex issue and
my concerns are that there have been
comments which in in my understanding
are just not accurate so
for those reasons i i i'm uncomfortable
passing something that that's
problematic in in my estimation so
i i would support an interim study
further discussion
representative run
yeah i mean
we've voted on ought to pass on many
bills that were a lot more vague
and um
if i could ask you to hold on a minute
representative got cool to get you to
click off your microphone okay
i just think this is pretty
straightforward um i think nashua and
any community that has
a cap needs to have an override
provision
the last thing we want to do is delay
this i think we should just just
vote no on the interim study so that
another motion can be made and we can
get this into statute thank you thank
you any further discussion
seeing none
we'll ask oh
yes representative guthrie
i just like to explain somewhat why i
voted no
and that i don't think it should go into
an interim study we have a member of our
committee from the uh
town that has a problem our city has a
problem i think we ought to have the
bill go forward let the senate take a
look at it and i just think they ought
to have an opportunity to move this bill
along i don't know enough about it i am
voting in the dark but it wouldn't be
the first time thank you
thank you representative representative
power thank you mr chair if a particular
town has an issue
i'm not sure why they can't fix that in
their their charter if that is in fact
an issue
thank you uh
seeing no further comment
uh we're gonna ask the clerk to call the
question
this is a a
motion
to interim study
house bill 1342.
vice chairman pmonty yes clerk votes yes
representative tripp
yes
representative guthrie no
representative los alas yes
representative mcdonald yes
representative melvin no
representative here
no
representative power yes
representative majori
no
representative
representative gilman no
representatives davis no representative
newman
no
representative fan no
representative klee
no
representative gallagher
and representative no
and
chairman dolan
i can't move fast enough today
uh motion fails uh seven to twelve okay
the motion for interim study has failed
so
uh we're available to make a new motion
yes representative
uh yes uh thank you mr chairman i a
motion to um ought to pass please and i
encourage everybody to say yes thank you
so much i second that
ocean has been made in second day
further discussion on the
motion to otp
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the
question
okay uh otp vice chairman pm monty no
clerk votes yes
representative tripp
no
representative guthrie yes
representative silas
no
representative mcbride
uh sorry macdonald uh no
representative melvin yes
representative er
yes
representative power
no
representative majori
representative
yes
representative gilman
no
she said it pretty forcefully yeah
representatives davis
representative uh newman
yes
representative vann
representative clee
yes
representative gallagher
no i've
yes
uh chairman dolan
i believe it's 13 to 6.
13 to 6 in the affirmative
12 to 6
12 what do you get jim 12 to 7 okay yeah
close enough
i will do that sir thank you
well again thank you
thank you all very much
we're concluding our session today
with no bills
in the backlog
uh
don't we have like three bills that
[Music]
deal with veterans tax credit that we're
talking about
financial notes
those are
oh okay thank you
mr chairman
if i could one of our
colleagues
expressed a great deal of anxiety
with respect to
a bill that she was very passionate
about
and she also
expressed that she was not looking
forward to talking
on the house floor
because she hadn't
talked on the house floor before
and might i just
say that
she displayed no anxiety
today and as long as she wears that
beautiful flower in her hair i'm sure
she'll do fine on the house floor
thank you representative
thank you mr chair i would echo
representative los salas's
observations of representative clee
she's quite
capable
measured
smart and passionate i can go either way
on the flower
you